Shure: 我要把头发扎起来太长了
Shure: I need to tie my hair up, it's too long.
Tasha: 以假乱真一朵
Tasha: It looks so real.
Tasha: 不会谢掉吧
Tasha: It won't wither, right?
Jake:火这糖怎么办
Jake: What should we do with this sugar?
Jake:给它融了倒掉是吧
Jake: Melt it and pour it out, right?
Shure: 哦这还有两个真好
Shure: Oh, there are two more, great.
Jake:呃我看一下
Jake: Uh, let me check.
Jake:问一下
Jake: Let me ask.
Jake:喂
Jake: Hello?
Jake:Rainbow人吗
Jake: Are you from Rainbow?
Jake:这小包要不要一个
Jake: Do you want one of these small bags?
Jake:收拾好了
Jake: All packed up.
Katrina: 走不走看狗去
Katrina: Are we going to see the dog?
Katrina: 然后要回来搞搞饭了
Katrina: Then we need to come back and cook.
Shure: 走
Shure: Let's go.
Jake:对去看狗吧
Jake: Yes, let's go see the dog.
Shure: 走
Shure: Let's go.
Katrina: 他还在吗
Katrina: Is he still there?
Katrina: 他俩去吗
Katrina: Are they going?
Katrina: 你们俩去吗
Katrina: Are you two going?
Katrina: 你俩去吗
Katrina: Are you guys going?
Jake:你俩开导了吗
Jake: Have you guys comforted him?
Alice:卫生间收了吗
Alice: Did you clean the bathroom?
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Lucia: 哦对
Lucia: Oh, right.
Lucia: 楼上那个洗手间也换一下可以吗
Lucia: Can you also change the garbage bag in the upstairs bathroom?
Lucia: 就是垃圾袋
Lucia: Just the garbage bag.
Lucia: 哦好谢谢啊
Lucia: Oh, thanks a lot.
Lucia: 哦也行
Lucia: Oh, that's fine too.
Shure: 这箱子我们留着还有点用
Shure: Let's keep this box, it might come in handy.
Jake:谢谢您
Jake: Thank you.
Jake:搁哪呢
Jake: Where should we put it?
Jake:搁这呢
Jake: Let's put it here.
Lucia: 啊可以的
Lucia: Ah, that's fine.
Lucia: 只要就是主要就是那个垃圾桶
Lucia: Just mainly the trash can.
Lucia: 收拾一下就行了
Lucia: Just tidy it up a bit.
Lucia: 呃这边的这些箱纸箱吗
Lucia: Uh, these boxes here?
Lucia: 这这这这个都可以不要了然后
Lucia: This, this, this, we don't need these anymore, then...
Lucia: 呃这个这个也不要了
Lucia: Uh, we don't need this either.
Lucia: 这里面这些我看一眼啊应该
Lucia: Let me take a look at what's inside, it should...
Jake:研究完了
Jake: Research is done.
Jake:研究出了idea
Jake: Came up with an idea.
Lucia: 对这都是不用了
Lucia: Yeah, we don't need these.
Jake:idea出来了
Jake: The idea is out.
Alice:呃一个比较杂乱的idea
Alice: Uh, a somewhat messy idea.
Lucia: 对对然后这也是
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, and this too.
Jake:OK行
Jake: Okay, got it.
Lucia: 嗯对那个应该是外卖垃圾
Lucia: Hmm, yeah, that should be the takeout trash.
Jake:那一块可以聊聊
Jake: We can talk about that part.
Lucia: 对对对然后这个这个箱子也不要了
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, and we don't need this box either.
Katrina: 你知道就是嗯那种
Katrina: You know, like, um, that kind of...
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Katrina: 就是小玩偶然后他可以抱在那个
Katrina: Like those little dolls that can hang on...
Katrina: 就是这种门把手上那个叫什么挂件吗
Katrina: Like on door handles. What are they called? Keychains?
Alice:门把手挂机
Alice: Door handle hangers.
Katrina: 就是嗯包括你有一个这样的圆柱子
Katrina: Like, um, and if you have a cylinder like this.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Katrina: 那个东西可以这样抱着他叫什么
Katrina: That thing can hug it. What's it called?
Alice:那什么啪啪圈什么
Alice: What, those slap bracelets?
Katrina: 我不知道搜什么关键词哎
Katrina: I don't know what keywords to search for.
Alice:你可以试着搜类似的然后看有没有
Alice: You can try searching for something similar and see if it shows up.
Alice:啪啪圈试着搜一下
Alice: Try searching for slap bracelets.
Shure: 哦我前两天看那个
Shure: Oh, I saw this meme a couple of days ago...
Shure: 一个表情包啪啪屈原的图然然后
Shure: A meme with Qu Yuan and some slap bracelets...
Jake:呃对齐一下
Jake: Uh, align it.
Jake:对齐之后就可以
Jake: Once aligned, it's good to go.
Katrina: 就就还有那种可以
Katrina: There's also the kind that...
Katrina: 就是你背书包上
Katrina: You can put on your backpack.
Katrina: 他有抱在你书包上的那种
Katrina: It hugs your backpack like that.
Shure: 然后说这
Shure: And then this...
Katrina: 叫什么挂件
Katrina: What's it called? Keychain?
Shure: 这是我们小时候玩的最早的SM哈哈哈
Shure: This was our earliest childhood S&M, haha.
Katrina: 哈哈够了真的是
Katrina: Haha, enough already, seriously.
Katrina: 走吧你们去不去散散步
Katrina: Let's go, are you guys coming for a walk?
Lucia: 哎咱门口就是
Lucia: Hey, right outside our door...
Jake:看看时间先看这个
Jake: Check the time, let's look at this first.
Lucia: 那那些箱子是已经收拾过的吗
Lucia: Are those boxes already packed?
Jake:然后
Jake: And then...
Lucia: 门口最最最最头这些这些我不太确定
Lucia: The ones right at the front, I’m not really sure about those.
Shure: 有点稀了
Shure: It's a bit sparse.
Shure: 但是问题不大
Shure: But it's not a big deal.
Shure: 本来是水多了
Shure: Originally, it had too much water.
Shure: 放盐盐多了
Shure: And then I added too much salt.
Katrina: 你你吃麻酱还是吃什么酱
Katrina: Do you eat sesame paste or some other sauce?
Alice:我只吃麻酱
Alice: I only eat sesame paste.
Alice:我不吃油碟吃不了
Alice: I can't handle the oily dip.
Alice:你吃油碟
Alice: Do you eat the oily dip?
Katrina: 油碟醋
Katrina: Oily dip with vinegar.
Shure: 其实本来是应该加酱油
Shure: Actually, we should've added soy sauce.
Katrina: 香菜
Katrina: And cilantro.
Katrina: 买了买了
Katrina: I bought it, I bought it.
Shure: 或者生抽来调这个咸味
Shure: Or use light soy sauce to adjust the saltiness.
Katrina: 对对对
Katrina: Yes, yes, yes.
Lucia: 这些盒好像都还挺结实可以放一下
Lucia: These containers seem pretty sturdy, we can store them.
Katrina: 昨天没买酱油
Katrina: We didn't buy soy sauce yesterday.
Katrina: 是吧无所谓吧
Katrina: Right? It's okay, right?
Katrina: 都能吃但我不吃麻酱
Katrina: It's all edible, but I don't eat sesame paste.
Shure: 你们怎么私闯我的房间呢
Shure: How did you guys break into my room?
Katrina: 够不够
Katrina: Is it enough?
Katrina: go go
Katrina: Go, go.
Jake:暗中
Jake: Secretly.
Lucia: 哎又校准一次
Lucia: Oh, calibrate it again.
Shure: 你要你要
Shure: You need to...
Shure: 你要在我这里面开
Shure: You need to open it in my room.
Jake:不亮了
Jake: It's not lighting up.
Jake:那是怎么回事
Jake: What's going on?
Katrina: 走不走走不走
Katrina: Are we going or not?
Jake:看看你的电
Jake: Check your power.
Katrina: 要走赶紧走
Katrina: If we're going, let's go quickly.
Jake:还是他会这有电
Jake: Or maybe it still has some power.
Jake:插上的
Jake: It's plugged in.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Alright, alright.
Katrina: 很艺术你看那画家的感觉走不走
Katrina: Very artistic, see that painter's vibe? Are we going or not?
Shure: 谢
Shure: Thanks.
Shure: 霓虹几乌鸡豆
Shure: Neon chicken soup.
Jake:按一下才能充
Jake: Press it to charge.
Shure: 走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Katrina: 溜一圈回来
Katrina: Let's take a quick stroll.
Shure: 走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Shure: 咱去走
Shure: Let's go for a walk.
Katrina: 他俩上厕所要等他俩吗
Katrina: Should we wait for them to finish in the bathroom?
Shure: 哪有人上厕所
Shure: Who's in the bathroom?
Katrina: 不知道啊
Katrina: I have no idea.
Katrina: 两小时衣服就干了
Katrina: Clothes dry in two hours.
Katrina: 我靠这大太阳爽了
Katrina: Wow, this big sun is awesome.
Katrina: 我来帮他踩一点户外的景开
Katrina: I'm going to help him explore some outdoor scenes.
Katrina: 开辟一些新地图
Katrina: Open up some new maps.
Katrina: 你记得是往左还是往右吗
Katrina: Do you remember if it's left or right?
Shure: 我记得
Shure: I remember.
Katrina: 哎这那有只小猫咪书包里毛条还在
Katrina: Hey, there's a little kitten, and the fur strip in the backpack is still there.
Katrina: 我们宿舍楼下有一只吃的巨肥
Katrina: There's a really fat cat under our dorm building.
Katrina: 我靠跟老虎一样
Katrina: Wow, it's as big as a tiger.
Katrina: 然后嘴巴还歪了
Katrina: And its mouth is crooked.
Katrina: 好像是口角炎吧
Katrina: I think it has stomatitis.
Katrina: 因为学校里有很多猫咪
Katrina: Because there are a lot of cats in the school.
Katrina: 哇两只
Katrina: Wow, two of them.
Katrina: 昨天只看一只
Katrina: Saw only one yesterday.
Katrina: 昨天看他的眼
Katrina: Looked at its eye yesterday.
Katrina: 眼睛还是蓝色
Katrina: Its eyes were still blue.
Katrina: 呀
Katrina: Ah.
Katrina: 还没怎么呢就跑
Katrina: It ran away before I could do anything.
Katrina: 还有一只我和你说哇一筒哎
Katrina: There's another one, I tell you. Wow, a whole tube!
Katrina: 倒没这么吓人吧
Katrina: It's not that scary, right?
Katrina: 看一下别的房间怎么装饰
Katrina: Let's see how other rooms are decorated.
Shure: 是这边吧
Shure: Is it this way?
Katrina: 我不知道啊
Katrina: I don't know.
Katrina: 好像是这边吧
Katrina: Maybe it's this way?
Katrina: 是不是是不是这出去然后右边就是
Katrina: Is it, is it this way and then to the right?
Shure: 不是我们草
Shure: No, our grass...
Shure: 不是那边
Shure: It's not that way.
Shure: 那就是那边
Shure: It must be the other way.
Katrina: 这样我们回去他们刚好上完厕所
Katrina: If we go back, they'll be done with the bathroom.
Katrina: 我们就不说我们走错了
Katrina: We won't tell them we got lost.
Katrina: 我说我们出来遛遛
Katrina: I'll say we went for a walk.
Shure: 提前呼吸一下新鲜空气啊
Shure: We got some fresh air beforehand.
Shure: 果然是那边
Shure: It really is that way.
Shure: 完了追不上了
Shure: We're done, we can't catch up.
Katrina: 他俩问我们干啥去了从建地图去了
Katrina: If they ask where we went, we'll say we were mapping new areas.
Shure: 他们逃我们追
Shure: They run, we chase.
Shure: 他们插翅难飞
Shure: They can't escape us.
Katrina: 笑死
Katrina: LOL
Katrina: 每天晚上
Katrina: Every night
Katrina: 感觉那个梁靖康有好多事情要做
Katrina: It feels like Liang Jingkang has a lot to do
Katrina: 他要给这
Katrina: He has to
Katrina: 么多充电宝充电
Katrina: charge so many power banks
Katrina: 他还要那么多摄像头
Katrina: He also needs so many cameras
Katrina: 还有眼镜也要充电
Katrina: And even his glasses need charging
Katrina: 还要导数据
Katrina: He has to transfer data too
Katrina: 感觉他一个脑子掰成n个脑子
Katrina: Feels like his brain has to split into a million parts
Katrina: 都不够用
Katrina: and it's still not enough
Shure: 这是PhD的脑袋
Shure: That's a PhD brain for you
Katrina: 每一个脑细胞都能单独工作
Katrina: Every brain cell works on its own
Shure: 我们就只能混成一坨屎来工作
Shure: While we can only work like a pile of crap
Katrina: 混成一坨屎
Katrina: A pile of crap
Katrina: 一件事还做不好
Katrina: and still can't do one thing right
Shure: 我就是单合单县城
Shure: I am just a single small town
Katrina: 吃火锅吃火锅
Katrina: Let's eat hotpot, eat hotpot
Katrina: 哇战斗机
Katrina: Wow, a fighter jet
Shure: 这不能乱看哈哈哈
Shure: You can't just look at these things, haha
Katrina: 哈哈哈真的是
Katrina: Haha, really
Shure: 这容易被抓起来的
Shure: You might get caught for this
Katrina: 好像是这花香
Katrina: Seems like it's this flower scent
Katrina: 是不是当时去天津的时候
Katrina: Was it when we went to Tianjin
Katrina: 天津也有很多这个花
Katrina: Tianjin also had a lot of these flowers
Katrina: 嗯这花还挺香
Katrina: Yeah, this flower smells nice
Katrina: 你们那工作室一般流程是什么
Katrina: What's the usual process in your studio
Katrina: 就是看哪个比较火
Katrina: Do you look for the trending ones
Katrina: 你们去把它版权一般多少钱
Katrina: How much do you usually pay for the rights
Shure: 对买下来
Shure: Yes, buy them
Katrina: 版权
Katrina: The rights
Katrina: 谈商务吗
Katrina: Do you do business talks
Katrina: 就是跟那个歌手去对接
Katrina: Like directly with the singers
Shure: 对谈商务
Shure: Yes, business talks
Shure: 合作模式
Shure: Collaboration models
Shure: 一般都是经纪人或者是制作公司
Shure: It's usually the agents or production companies
Katrina: 哎那你们这样的话是不是还可以
Katrina: Oh, so you get to
Katrina: 就是接触到一些明星啊
Katrina: meet some celebrities too
Shure: 啊姜云生前两天还过来的哇
Shure: Yeah, Jiang Yunsheng came by the other day, wow
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow
Shure: 我们云生就是他一直我们就有合作
Shure: Yunsheng, we've always been working together
Shure: 他这好多
Shure: He has a lot of them.
Shure: 就是一半的胳膊都是跟我们弄的
Shure: Half of his arm is made by us.
Katrina: 可好玩啊
Katrina: It's so much fun.
Katrina: 今天不能喝咖啡
Katrina: I can't drink coffee today.
Katrina: 今天喝两杯了
Katrina: I've already had two cups today.
Katrina: 再喝睡不着喽
Katrina: If I drink more, I won't be able to sleep.
Shure: 你们在撸狗吗
Shure: Are you guys petting a dog?
Katrina: 哎这么亲人的吗
Katrina: Hey, it's so affectionate.
Shure: 我可以扒你的裤子吗
Shure: Can I take off your pants?
Katrina: 这是边牧吧
Katrina: Is this a Border Collie?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes, it is.
Katrina: 呀好可爱
Katrina: Oh, so cute.
Katrina: 他舔我
Katrina: He's licking me.
Katrina: 我一直想养只小狗
Katrina: I've always wanted to have a puppy.
Katrina: 我妈不给我养
Katrina: But my mom won't let me.
Katrina: 不能咬我的线
Katrina: Don't bite my wire.
Katrina: 生命之线
Katrina: It's my lifeline.
Katrina: 断电了我这赛博生命就不存在了
Katrina: If it gets disconnected, my cyber life is over.
Katrina: 他叫什么名字
Katrina: What's his name?
Katrina: 这么大应该是几个月吧
Katrina: He must be a few months old.
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Katrina: 哈嗯
Katrina: Ha, hmm.
Nicous: 他也不叫
Nicous: He doesn't even bark.
Shure: 唤醒它一些
Shure: Wake him up a bit.
Katrina: 他他的牙长没
Katrina: Are his teeth grown?
Shure: 他怎么不搭理我呢
Shure: Why is he ignoring me?
Shure: 是我语法错误太多了吗
Shure: Is it because my grammar is too bad?
Katrina: 你的狗语不太对没听懂
Katrina: Your dog language is off, he doesn't understand.
Shure: 我的生命线断了
Shure: My lifeline is broken.
Katrina: 他即将出现在我们这个赛博世界里
Katrina: He will soon appear in our cyber world.
Katrina: 也有会也会有小狗
Katrina: There will also be puppies.
Shure: 他那些不该看的地方都被我们看光了
Shure: We have seen all the places we shouldn't see.
Katrina: 小孩子嘛不懂
Katrina: He's just a kid, doesn't understand.
Shure: 你是说谁不懂
Shure: Who are you saying doesn't understand?
Nicous: 拍张照赛博
Nicous: Take a photo, cyber style.
Katrina: 把他这样刻进来
Katrina: Let's carve him in like this.
Shure: 你不要老用你的钉钉对着我们好吗
Shure: Can you stop pointing your DingTalk at us?
Katrina: 请你斯文一点
Katrina: Please be more civilized.
Katrina: 我家之前养一只金渐层
Katrina: I used to have a British Shorthair.
Katrina: 不会埋屎
Katrina: It wouldn't bury its poop.
Katrina: 把我妈臭的
Katrina: My mom stinks.
Katrina: 长牙了吗
Katrina: Has it grown teeth?
Shure: 它长你让它咬你一口你就知道了
Shure: If it has, let it bite you once and you'll know.
Katrina: 我去
Katrina: Oh my god.
Katrina: 呀呀呀呀呀呀哎呀哈哈
Katrina: Ah ah ah ah ah ah ha ha.
Katrina: 给他俩耳巴子
Katrina: Give it a slap on the ear.
Shure: 本来我们还要参加一个比赛的
Shure: Actually, we were supposed to join a competition.
Shure: 过一段
Shure: After a while.
Katrina: 什么大四了还参加
Katrina: What, you're in your fourth year and still joining?
Shure: 乐队的比赛
Shure: It's a band competition.
Katrina: 啊可以啊出道呀
Katrina: Ah, that's great, you can debut!
Katrina: 出道直接网易云千里了
Katrina: If you debut, you'll be on NetEase Cloud immediately.
Katrina: 嗯多帅啊
Katrina: Hmm, how cool would that be?
Katrina: 哎不是他真的好不斯文拍的
Katrina: Hey, he's really not polite in the photo.
Katrina: 拍个上半身
Katrina: Take a picture of his upper body.
Shure: 或者你可以全身拍
Shure: Or you can take a full-body shot.
Shure: 然后给他打个码
Shure: And then blur it out.
Katrina: 哈哈你倒是蛮考虑周到
Katrina: Ha ha, you're quite considerate.
Shure: 就看着会更诡异些
Shure: It would look creepier.
Shure: 保护狗四
Shure: Protect the dog.
Katrina: 刚开始的小狗就是小小的
Katrina: Puppies are small at first.
Katrina: 要训练一下
Katrina: They need training.
Katrina: 就不准咬人是不是
Katrina: So they don't bite people, right?
Katrina: 那那就是它如果咬了
Katrina: If it bites,
Katrina: 你就打它
Katrina: You should hit it.
Shure: 七八岁讨狗嫌是
Shure: At seven or eight years old, it's annoying.
Katrina: 哇这样看很可爱哎哎哎
Katrina: Wow, it looks so cute like this.
Katrina: 摸一下
Katrina: Touch it.
Nicous: 纯的专门挑的这个好的
Nicous: Purebred, picked the best one.
Katrina: 又咬又咬
Katrina: It's biting again.
Katrina: 什么东西啊
Katrina: What is this?
Nicous: 每个动感
Nicous: Every dynamic.
Katrina: 哦他现在吃冻干哎呦
Katrina: Oh, it's eating freeze-dried food now.
Nicous: 来准个二锅头
Nicous: Let's get some Erguotou.
Shure: 他要看一些不该看的东西哈哈哈
Shure: He's looking at things he shouldn't be looking at, ha ha ha.
Katrina: 没有穿个安全裤
Katrina: No, he's wearing safety pants.
Katrina: 琢磨起我脚来了
Katrina: He's studying my foot.
Shure: 角力
Shure: Wrestling.
Shure: 与公牛角力
Shure: Wrestling with a bull.
Shure: 还有串不能要
Shure: There's a bunch you can't have.
Katrina: 诶呀哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha!
Katrina: 哼哼
Katrina: Hmph hmph.
Shure: 你把你手机拿拿远点
Shure: Move your phone a bit further away.
Katrina: 咬你了
Katrina: It bit you.
Katrina: 他能听懂啥指令不呀
Katrina: Can it understand any commands?
Katrina: 不能咬我线
Katrina: Don't bite my cable.
Katrina: 我生命线
Katrina: It's my lifeline.
Katrina: 又来咬我鞋了
Katrina: It's biting my shoe again.
Katrina: 呀
Katrina: Ah!
Katrina: 跳哎
Katrina: Jump, hey!
Katrina: 跳他不会跳
Katrina: It can't jump.
Katrina: 杨老板要是知道我这样玩线完蛋了
Katrina: If Jake knew I was messing with the cable like this, I'd be in trouble.
Shure: 这栅栏就是防他的是吗
Shure: Is this fence to prevent him?
Nicous: 商品在哪里买的哪里便宜一点得物吗
Nicous: Where can I buy the product where it's cheaper? On Dewu?
Katrina: 得物可以
Katrina: Dewu is fine.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina: 等下需求是什么
Katrina: Hold on, what's the need?
Katrina: 就是它是过节吗
Katrina: Is it for a festival?
Katrina: 还是已经选好了
Katrina: Or have you already chosen?
Katrina: 选好了就是淘宝的话
Katrina: If you've chosen, then Taobao is good.
Katrina: 嗯那那你就是要再靠谱一点的
Katrina: Hmm, then you need something more reliable.
Katrina: 那个店就是
Katrina: That shop is...
Katrina: 这得具体分析
Katrina: It needs detailed analysis.
Katrina: 我没法给你具体
Katrina: I can't give you specifics.
Katrina: 我给你找找我经常买的那几家
Katrina: I'll find the shops I usually buy from.
Nicous: 那我加你微信
Nicous: Then I'll add you on WeChat.
Katrina: 行
Katrina: Okay.
Katrina: 一般那种海淘的店会就是那种小店
Katrina: Generally, those overseas purchasing shops are small.
Katrina: 会不会有假货
Katrina: Would they sell fake goods?
Katrina: 但是那种很大几十万粉丝
Katrina: But those with hundreds of thousands of followers...
Shure: 哎呀你这也能加一张
Shure: Oh man, you can add one more here.
Katrina: 就可能会有假
Katrina: It might be fake.
Shure: 太太牛逼了
Shure: That's impressive.
Nicous: 啊你打我屁股
Nicous: Ah, you hit my butt.
Katrina: 货哎
Katrina: Ouch!
Katrina: 他怎么攻击你
Katrina: How did it attack you?
Nicous: 打我屁股真的是
Nicous: It hit my butt, seriously.
Katrina: 直接在群里加你吗
Katrina: Should I add you in the group?
Katrina: 这是嘛
Katrina: Is this it?
Nicous: 对就这
Nicous: Yeah, that's it.
Shure: 叫自由制造
Shure: Call it "Freedom Manufacturing"
Shure: 哎呦太土了这个名字
Shure: Oh man, that name is so cheesy.
Katrina: 你叫啥来着
Katrina: What's your name again?
Katrina: 他直接把选好了然后你挑就行是吧
Katrina: He just picks it directly, and then you just choose, right?
Nicous: 还真是啊
Nicous: Yeah, that's right.
Katrina: 可以啊这相处模式
Katrina: This way of interacting is pretty good.
Nicous: 已经选好了啊
Nicous: It's already selected, huh?
Katrina: 就就是那种给你一个范围
Katrina: So, it's like they give you a range
Katrina: 然后让你自己挑是吗
Katrina: and then you pick yourself, right?
Katrina: 那么多全要买
Katrina: You have to buy all of them?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Nicous: 对全麦
Nicous: Yes, the whole wheat.
Katrina: 这是什么节吗
Katrina: What event is this?
Katrina: 还是就普通的没有节
Katrina: Or is it just an ordinary day?
Katrina: 爽嘞
Katrina: Awesome!
Jake:you
Jake: you
Katrina: 其实得物的话他的货源也是个人啊
Katrina: Actually, for DeWu, the suppliers are individuals too.
Katrina: 拜拜
Katrina: Bye-bye.
Katrina: 货源也是个
Katrina: The suppliers are also...
Katrina: 也还行得物也还行
Katrina: DeWu is still okay.
Katrina: 得物的真真假假
Katrina: There's a mix of real and fake on DeWu.
Katrina: 他那个帖子太多
Katrina: There are too many posts.
Katrina: 我到现在也没明白
Katrina: I still don't get it.
Katrina: 得物的到底是真还是假
Katrina: Is DeWu real or fake?
Nicous: 得物也不一定假
Nicous: DeWu isn't necessarily fake.
Katrina: 好几个系列呢毛戈平
Katrina: There are several series, Mao Geping.
Katrina: 你知道这啥牌子
Katrina: Do you know this brand?
Katrina: 我半身退一下因为像
Katrina: I'll step back because like...
Nicous: 我靠这个季度茶来了太好玩了
Nicous: Wow, the tea of this season is here, so much fun.
Katrina: 对今天又有素材了
Katrina: Yeah, today we have new material.
Katrina: 就直接说帮助人家挑
Katrina: Just directly help people pick.
Nicous: 老老外人又傻了
Nicous: Foreigners are dumbfounded again.
Katrina: 老外说外面这么发达
Katrina: Foreigners say it's so advanced outside.
Katrina: 这是新款吗
Katrina: Is this a new model?
Katrina: 这这个羽翼无瑕好像之前没有哎
Katrina: This "Flawless Wings" seems new, wasn't there before.
Nicous: 其实他也不懂
Nicous: Actually, he doesn't understand either.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah?
Katrina: 他什么皮你知道吗
Katrina: Do you know his skin type?
Katrina: 干皮油皮
Katrina: Dry or oily?
Katrina: 你
Katrina: You...
Nicous: 他就是前段时间突然因为后边可能要出去玩他就仔细学了一下
Nicous: He just started learning carefully recently because he might go out to play later.
Nicous: 找人学了一下怎么化妆然后调了好多挑了一晚上吧
Nicous: He found someone to teach him how to do makeup and tried a lot, spent a whole night on it.
Nicous: 我那会淘宝找不到了
Nicous: I couldn't find it on Taobao back then.
Katrina: 这是新品因为没有带过电出来
Katrina: This is a new product because it hasn't been powered on before.
Nicous: 官网有吗
Nicous: Is it available on the official website?
Katrina: 官网有
Katrina: Yes, it's on the official website.
Nicous: 这个没
Nicous: Not this one.
Katrina: 嗯你看他有没有那种
Katrina: Hmm, see if there’s one of those.
Nicous: 这个泡澡是吧
Nicous: This one is for bathing, right?
Katrina: 等下我们看看
Katrina: Wait, let's take a look.
Katrina: 这个是气垫加替换装
Katrina: This is a cushion with a refill.
Katrina: 这是两套
Katrina: These are two sets.
Katrina: 可以先买一个试试
Katrina: You can buy one to try first.
Katrina: 我觉得因为不好用的话
Katrina: I think because if it's not good to use,
Katrina: 那替换装就浪费了
Katrina: the refill would be wasted.
Katrina: 你就买360就行
Katrina: You can just buy the 360 one.
Katrina: 但是你要看
Katrina: But you need to check.
Katrina: 他什么色号
Katrina: What shade it is.
Katrina: 应该应该是买白一点的
Katrina: It should be a lighter one.
Nicous: 我想买这个
Nicous: I want to buy this one.
Nicous: 怎么说
Nicous: What do you think?
Katrina: 是这系列吧
Katrina: Is it from this series?
Katrina: 我刚刚实图实穿雨衣系列
Katrina: I just tried on the raincoat series.
Nicous: 十分话这个是
Nicous: Absolutely, this is it.
Katrina: 他一般女生我觉得都得买这个最白的
Katrina: Generally, I think most girls would buy the lightest one.
Katrina: 这咖啡店使我们名宿老板开的吗
Katrina: Is this coffee shop opened by the owner of our B&B?
Nicous: 恩是另一个
Nicous: Yeah, another one.
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Katrina: 精品还是上官网买
Katrina: For premium items, you should buy from the official website.
Katrina: 其他的可以
Katrina: Other things are okay.
Katrina: 经典款可以去别的地
Katrina: Classic styles can be bought elsewhere.
Nicous: 这有颜色吗
Nicous: Does this have a color?
Nicous: 80E哦因该写80E
Nicous: 80E, oh, it should say 80E.
Katrina: 一般都是最白这个色
Katrina: It's usually the lightest color.
Katrina: 801吧
Katrina: 801, right?
Nicous: 这个
Nicous: This one.
Katrina: 他如果某一个品牌买的特别多的话
Katrina: If you buy a lot from a particular brand,
Katrina: 你都可以去专柜
Katrina: you can go to the counter.
Katrina: 他有那个折扣
Katrina: They have discounts.
Katrina: 这什么香奈儿粉饼
Katrina: What is this, Chanel powder?
Katrina: 这个我好像知道
Katrina: I think I know this.
Katrina: 我给你找
Katrina: I'll find it for you.
Katrina: 真狗假狗
Katrina: Real dog or fake dog?
Katrina: 我舍友问怎么了
Katrina: My roommate asked what's going on.
Katrina: 小狗叫成这样
Katrina: The puppy is barking like this.
Nicous: 真狗假狗
Nicous: Real dog or fake dog?
Katrina: 这粉饼我好像用过我这里找找
Katrina: I think I've used this powder before, let me look.
Nicous: 好用吗
Nicous: Is it good?
Katrina: 还不错
Katrina: Not bad.
Katrina: 香奈儿光彩粉饼
Katrina: Chanel's brightening powder.
Katrina: 这也得买最白的
Katrina: You have to get the whitest one.
Nicous: 你当时用这个
Nicous: Did you use this at that time?
Katrina: 因为香奈儿的恩代购吧好像
Katrina: Because it's Chanel, probably from a personal shopper.
Katrina: 给我看看他那个是不是这个
Katrina: Let me see if his is the same.
Katrina: 是这个吧
Katrina: This is the one, right?
Nicous: 是的
Nicous: Yes.
Katrina: 因为他最近升级新版了
Katrina: Because he recently upgraded to a new version.
Nicous: 他升级新版了
Nicous: He upgraded to a new version.
Katrina: 他升级新版
Katrina: He upgraded.
Katrina: 就是嗯变宽了
Katrina: It got wider.
Katrina: 但我觉得还是以前的好看
Katrina: But I still think the previous one looked better.
Nicous: 就以前这个不要这版
Nicous: Just the old one, not this version.
Nicous: 就这家店吗
Nicous: Is it from this store?
Katrina: 我再给你找找
Katrina: I'll look for you again.
Nicous: 现在都买新版比较多
Nicous: Now most people buy the new version.
Nicous: 你你你有什么买过的我改
Nicous: What did you buy that I can change?
Katrina: 香奈儿的话代购店不多
Katrina: For Chanel, there aren't many personal shopper stores.
Katrina: 一般都是海淘
Katrina: Usually it's overseas shopping.
Nicous: 那就把
Nicous: Then just...
Katrina: 官网可以去官网会送东西去
Katrina: You can go to the official website, they give gifts.
Katrina: 他的那个不是淘宝店官网
Katrina: It's not a Taobao store, it's their official website.
Katrina: 而是他的网站官
Katrina: You buy directly from there.
Katrina: 你就直接这样买
Katrina: You can write a card for him.
Katrina: 你可以给他写卡片吗对啊
Katrina: You can write a card for him, right.
Katrina: 香香香香宝宝用香香粉饼
Katrina: Chanel baby uses Chanel powder.
Katrina: 小狗小狗
Katrina: Puppy, puppy.
Katrina: 耶哎呦
Katrina: Yay, oh my.
Katrina: 之前香奈儿官网的话会送三个小样
Katrina: Previously, Chanel's official website would give three samples.
Katrina: 送那个香水
Katrina: They gave perfume samples.
Nicous: 卧槽现在不送了
Nicous: Damn, they don't give them anymore.
Katrina: 先送呀
Katrina: Deliver it first.
Nicous: 没有
Nicous: No.
Katrina: 旗舰店不错
Katrina: The flagship store is good.
Katrina: 那个香奈儿的官网
Katrina: That Chanel's official website.
Nicous: 那我能在哪买吗
Nicous: Then where can I buy it?
Katrina: 可以一样的价格
Katrina: The price is the same.
Katrina: 哦小程序也行
Katrina: Oh, the mini-program works too.
Katrina: 我找找我好像也在小程序
Katrina: Let me check, I think it's also on the mini-program.
Katrina: 我靠我之前谈个什么恋爱我操
Katrina: Damn, what kind of relationship was I in before?
Nicous: 怎么说
Nicous: What do you mean?
Katrina: 没有人这么用心的被人对待过好吗
Katrina: No one has ever treated me so sincerely.
Nicous: 用心总会有的
Nicous: There will always be someone who does.
Nicous: 下一个更好
Nicous: The next one will be better.
Katrina: 嗯我也这么觉得
Katrina: Yeah, I think so too.
Katrina: 我他妈给他把那个色号给他发过去
Katrina: I sent him the exact color code.
Katrina: 他都能买错
Katrina: And he still got it wrong.
Nicous: 不行你让他下次直接打钱
Nicous: Next time, just have him transfer the money directly.
Katrina: 就很不想多说
Katrina: I really don't want to talk much about it.
Katrina: 看我那前男友
Katrina: Look at my ex.
Katrina: 我觉得就是你但凡用点心
Katrina: I feel like if he had put in a bit of effort...
Katrina: 像我当时给他买鼠标买高达的时候
Katrina: Like when I bought him a mouse and a Gundam.
Nicous: 卧槽怎么这种男生
Nicous: Damn, what kind of guy is that?
Katrina: 当时家教赚了
Katrina: I earned...
Katrina: 赚了有一万多吧
Katrina: I earned over ten thousand from tutoring.
Katrina: 那个寒假二暑假
Katrina: That winter and summer vacation.
Katrina: 然后给他买了个那个
Katrina: Then I bought him that thing.
Katrina: 就是他跟我晚上聊天的时候
Katrina: Just during a casual chat one night...
Katrina: 说什么他想换一个什么狗屁王二
Katrina: He mentioned he wanted to replace some crappy Wang Er.
Katrina: 然后给他买了
Katrina: So I bought it for him.
Nicous: 狗屁王也得八九百
Nicous: Wang Er costs eight or nine hundred too.
Katrina: 嗯差不多吧
Katrina: Yeah, roughly.
Katrina: 然后就是在一个普通的日子
Katrina: And it was just an ordinary day.
Katrina: 就给他买了
Katrina: I just bought it for him.
Katrina: 就是惊喜懂吗
Katrina: It was a surprise, you know?
Katrina: 但是我就没有收到过这种惊喜
Katrina: But I never received such a surprise.
Katrina: 就是非要那种什么某个节假日啊
Katrina: Always had to be on some holiday or something.
Katrina: 什么的然后他还问
Katrina: And then he would ask...
Katrina: 他还要问你
Katrina: He would still ask you...
Katrina: 他反而就是你想那只NARS的唇霜
Katrina: He would be like, "Do you want that NARS lip cream?"
Katrina: 还是在一起四年吧
Katrina: And we were together for four years.
Katrina: 四年的时候他才开始做功课
Katrina: He only started doing homework in the fourth year.
Nicous: 我们在一起这么久哦
Nicous: We've been together for so long.
Katrina: 我就谈了一段从高二谈到大三权益低
Katrina: I had a relationship from sophomore year in high school to junior year in college, and it wasn't very successful.
Katrina: 哈哈所以人家跟我说
Katrina: Haha, so people told me
Katrina: 我像那会谈了一段十几段一样
Katrina: that it seemed like I had a dozen relationships.
Nicous: 在官网搜不到这个
Nicous: Can't find this on the official website.
Katrina: 我给你找找我靠我特喜欢帮人就是买化妆品
Katrina: Let me look for it. I love helping people buy makeup.
Katrina: 我大一大二的时候研究过这些
Katrina: I studied these things in my freshman and sophomore years.
Katrina: 然后特开心
Katrina: It made me so happy.
Katrina: 然后就是很懂这些
Katrina: And I got really good at it.
Nicous: 官网是不是没有这个旧版
Nicous: The official website doesn't have the old version, right?
Katrina: 啊可能等下我给你找找
Katrina: Ah, maybe. Let me check for you.
Katrina: 因为就是你给女生买东西的话
Katrina: Because when you buy things for girls,
Katrina: 就是赠品多一点
Katrina: you get more freebies.
Katrina: 它的包装好看点
Katrina: The packaging is nicer.
Katrina: 你就会就会开心
Katrina: It makes you happy.
Katrina: 就觉得唉做功课划算
Katrina: You feel like doing homework is worth it.
Katrina: 当时他给我买错那色号也是官网买的
Katrina: Back then, he bought the wrong shade for me from the official website too.
Katrina: 也不能退我
Katrina: And I couldn't return it.
Katrina: 我真生气啊
Katrina: I was really angry.
Nicous: 哎我找到了
Nicous: Hey, I found it.
Katrina: 对就是这样
Katrina: Yes, that's it.
Katrina: 有那个B0
Katrina: There's the B0.
Katrina: 对一般都是B0
Katrina: Yes, it's usually B0.
Katrina: 他是可以选三个小样
Katrina: You can choose three samples.
Katrina: 送点香水啊洗面奶什么的
Katrina: They give you perfumes, face wash, etc.
Katrina: 他也可以带
Katrina: You can take them with you.
Katrina: 可以选3个吧我记得
Katrina: You can choose three, I remember.
Katrina: 可以就是那种带出去的
Katrina: They are the kind you can take out with you.
Katrina: 还可以选3个
Katrina: You can still choose three.
Katrina: 我建议这个
Katrina: I recommend this one.
Katrina: 还有这个然后哎这巴黎巴黎好闻
Katrina: And this one. Oh, this Paris one smells great.
Katrina: 因为他这两个精华不是很好用
Katrina: These two serums aren't very good.
Katrina: 有点搓泥
Katrina: They get a bit cakey.
Katrina: 你们俩出去玩的话
Katrina: If you two go out,
Katrina: 他这个眼唇卸跟洗面奶就带小样
Katrina: you can take the eye and lip remover and face wash samples.
Katrina: 可以出去嘛
Katrina: You can take them out.
Katrina: 然后这这个香水还是蛮多人推的
Katrina: And this perfume is quite popular.
Katrina: 三小样单买有100块钱这三个
Katrina: Three samples bought separately cost 100 yuan.
Katrina: 我靠我怎么就遇不到呢
Katrina: Why can't I ever find these deals?
Katrina: 难受啊好
Katrina: Feeling a bit down, alright.
Katrina: 今天AI又学学到了人类情感问题
Katrina: Today, the AI learned about human emotions again.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 我也买啊哈哈
Katrina: I'll buy it too, haha.
Katrina: 那天他就是睡得这我们俩麦咖啡的时候走了
Katrina: That day, he left when we were having our McCafe.
Katrina: 手机号注册一下
Katrina: Register with your phone number.
Katrina: 小哥评价出新款气垫了吗
Katrina: Did the guy review the new cushion?
Katrina: 你你一共谈了几个
Katrina: How many have you dated in total?
Nicous: 真正谈的就5个
Nicous: Actually dated, just 5.
Katrina: 什么时候开始弹起
Katrina: When did you start to dated?
Nicous: 初中的时候谈了一个然后高中谈了一个大学这就现在
Nicous: I dated one in middle school, one in high school, and then in college, and now.
Katrina: 能行呀
Katrina: That's impressive.
Nicous: 问就是一个
Nicous: Just one if you ask.
Katrina: 你女你现在的女朋友哪儿人啊
Katrina: Where's your current girlfriend from?
Katrina: 是北游的吗
Katrina: Is she from the North?
Katrina: 哦那你咋认识的呀
Katrina: Oh, how did you guys meet?
Nicous: 那不是网上匿名
Nicous: Wasn't it anonymous online?
Katrina: 就是从认识就一直是谈异地恋吗
Katrina: So, have you been in a long-distance relationship since you met?
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Katrina: 这种没有感情基础的异地恋能谈久吗
Katrina: Can a long-distance relationship without a solid foundation last long?
Katrina: 就是就是
Katrina: Yeah, exactly.
Katrina: 像因为像我当时谈着异地恋
Katrina: Because, like, when I was in a long-distance relationship.
Katrina: 是高中带上来的
Katrina: It started in high school.
Katrina: 就彼此认识一点
Katrina: We knew each other a bit.
Katrina: 但是就是
Katrina: But, like,
Katrina: 如果说两个人刚认识
Katrina: if two people just met,
Katrina: 刚相处就异地恋的话
Katrina: and started a long-distance relationship,
Katrina: 哦那还差不多
Katrina: Oh, that’s almost the same.
Katrina: 你当时只讲了前女友
Katrina: You only talked about your ex-girlfriend back then.
Katrina: 好可爱的狗
Katrina: Such a cute dog.
Katrina: 那你之后出国是吗他呢
Katrina: So are you going abroad afterward? What about her?
Nicous: 她才大二
Nicous: She's just a sophomore.
Katrina: 其实大家走一步看一步啦
Katrina: Honestly, take it one step at a time.
Katrina: 不用想那么多
Katrina: Don’t think too much.
Katrina: 唉那
Katrina: You know,
Katrina: 当时所有人还觉得
Katrina: back then, everyone thought
Katrina: 我这段恋爱谈的非常好呢
Katrina: I was doing great in my relationship.
Katrina: 我感觉
Katrina: I felt
Katrina: 你会感觉到有一点落差包括
Katrina: you might feel a bit of a gap, including
Katrina: 就可能觉得哎呀我俩相处熟了
Katrina: maybe thinking, “Oh, we’re pretty familiar now.”
Katrina: 就没那么用心了
Katrina: Just didn't put that much effort into it.
Katrina: 但是但是去年保研9月份
Katrina: But, but last year, during the graduate school recommendation in September...
Katrina: 9月底不是保研签那个系统吗
Katrina: At the end of September, isn't there a system for the recommendation?
Katrina: 9月初的时候
Katrina: At the beginning of September...
Katrina: 然后北航还有我自己来
Katrina: And then, there was Beihang University and myself...
Katrina: 他也没有给我任何帮助啊
Katrina: He didn't give me any help at all.
Katrina: 一些他考研我保研
Katrina: Some of them were for the entrance exam, while I was recommended.
Katrina: 压力来源也不一样
Katrina: The pressure sources were different.
Katrina: 哎说起来好复杂
Katrina: Ugh, it's so complicated.
Katrina: 不知道他上来没有
Katrina: Don't know if he's on or not.
Katrina: 把他全拉黑了
Katrina: Blocked him completely.
Katrina: 我靠当然是他先把我拉黑的好吗
Katrina: Come on, he blocked me first, okay?
Katrina: 我话还没打完
Katrina: I hadn't even finished my sentence.
Katrina: 我就是把那一发出去
Katrina: I just sent that message...
Katrina: 红感叹号哈哈哈
Katrina: And got a red exclamation mark, haha.
Katrina: 特别特别惨一小女孩啊
Katrina: Such a poor little girl, really.
Katrina: 啊这挂画竟然是巨兽的
Katrina: Ah, this hanging scroll is actually of a giant beast.
Katrina: 还有哦那几个我帮你先看看
Katrina: Also, those few, let me check them for you first.
Katrina: 你可以转给我
Katrina: You can send them to me.
Katrina: 就是你你你搞这些的时候我帮你看看
Katrina: Like, when you're doing these, I'll check them for you.
Katrina: 有事吗现在还哦
Katrina: Is there something going on now?
Katrina: 我看我还有多少内存
Katrina: Let me see how much memory I have left.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Katrina: 这这有两个
Katrina: There are two here.
Katrina: 这个修容券他要吗
Katrina: Does he want this contour voucher?
Katrina: 就是一个修容
Katrina: It's just a contour...
Katrina: 可以用很久很久可以用到那种
Katrina: You can use it for a very long time, like forever.
Katrina: 就这修容跟高光这一块修容
Katrina: This contour and highlight, this contour...
Katrina: 够你用一辈子都不会用不完
Katrina: Enough for you to use a lifetime, you'll never run out.
Katrina: 就是它另一个
Katrina: And there's another one.
Katrina: 第二个也是修容嘛
Katrina: The second one is also contour.
Katrina: 这个修容
Katrina: This contour...
Katrina: 这也是修容
Katrina: This one is also contour.
Katrina: 我感觉二选一就行
Katrina: I feel like just one of the two is enough.
Nicous: 这都拿这都那他
Nicous: Take both, take both, him...
Katrina: 这个今天非常丰富的情感哈哈
Katrina: Today has been full of emotions, haha.
Katrina: 今天杨老板会非常满意
Katrina: Today, Jake will be very satisfied.
Katrina: 又有肢体又有情感
Katrina: There's both physical and emotional content.
Tasha: 还有蒜蒜
Tasha: And garlic too.
Katrina: 好等一下
Katrina: Okay, wait a sec.
Shure: 应该不用吧
Shure: Probably not needed.
Katrina: 这是什么一直州长
Katrina: What is this about a governor?
Nicous: 好像是什么这个说什么非常好的
Nicous: It seems like someone said it's really good.
Katrina: 嗯这我我也有
Katrina: Yeah, I have this too.
Katrina: 用不完的
Katrina: Can't use it all up.
Katrina: 根本用不完
Katrina: Can't use it all up at all.
Katrina: 你也可以搬个凳子来学一
Katrina: You could also grab a chair and learn.
Katrina: 确实是
Katrina: Indeed.
Choiszt: 这个这个是气垫什么的
Choiszt: This, this is an air cushion or something.
Katrina: 就是就是粉底液灌进去了而已
Katrina: It's just liquid foundation poured into it.
Katrina: 然后这样就携带比较方便
Katrina: And it's more convenient to carry around this way.
Choiszt: 哎粉底不都是这种
Choiszt: Hey, aren't all foundations like this?
Nicous: 现在粉底都是液体的
Nicous: Now all foundations are liquid.
Katrina: 但是也有那种瓶装的
Katrina: But there are also bottled ones.
Katrina: 瓶装的你就得自己带粉扑
Katrina: For bottled ones, you need to bring your own puff.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 呀等下发错了
Katrina: Oops, sent it wrong.
Katrina: 这一把确实话有点多
Katrina: There was a bit too much talking this round.
Katrina: 你这感觉没两三千拿不下呀
Katrina: Feels like you can't get it for less than two or three thousand.
Tasha: 楼上有一个卡式炉
Tasha: There's a cassette stove upstairs.
Katrina: 而且有两瓶粉底液一个气垫
Katrina: And there are two bottles of foundation and a cushion.
Katrina: 我觉得这用一辈子用不完
Katrina: I think it would last a lifetime.
Katrina: 这个这个色号
Katrina: This, this shade.
Katrina: 这个色号比较多
Katrina: There are many shades.
Katrina: 你建议问清楚
Katrina: You should ask clearly.
Katrina: 774应该是比较适合774
Katrina: 774 should be more suitable, 774.
Katrina: 白皮肤是
Katrina: For fair skin.
Choiszt: 这个剪辑到时候就分析这两个男的怎么
Choiszt: When editing, just analyze how these two guys...
Katrina: 不是一般黄一白都用这个
Katrina: Usually, both yellow and fair use this one.
Nicous: 特备白
Nicous: Super fair.
Katrina: 特别白用584
Katrina: Super fair uses 584.
Katrina: 这个774是大家都比较适合
Katrina: 774 is suitable for most people.
Katrina: 特别特别白
Katrina: Super, super fair.
Nicous: 刘帅刘帅开始考虑这个时候到底要发内个
Nicous: Choiszt is considering whether to send it now.
Choiszt: 你这个就是啥时候给他呀
Choiszt: When are you going to give it to him?
Nicous: 我今天买他中午回家
Nicous: I bought it today and he went home at noon.
刘帅就算是什么时候
Choiszt: So when exactly?
Nicous: 这里算是算是算是他要的东西只能说
Nicous: This, this counts, it can be said to be what he wanted.
Katrina: 这我招惹招惹这个这好大一盒
Katrina: This, I messed with this, such a big box.
Choiszt: 这俩有什么区别
Choiszt: What's the difference between these two?
Katrina: 梁牌
Katrina: Liang brand
Katrina: 就跟牌子有关
Katrina: It's related to the brand
Katrina: 兰蔻会好一点
Katrina: Lancôme would be better
Choiszt: 那为什么不都买了
Choiszt: Then why not buy both?
Nicous: 那我内次他过生日他过生日过生日想要包就是我买了
Nicous: So last time it was his birthday, he wanted a bag, so I bought it for him.
Nicous: 然后我选的是四万这只能说明我眼光不一样
Nicous: And I chose a $40,000 one. This just shows that my taste is different.
Choiszt: 说明你有钱
Choiszt: It shows that you have money.
Nicous: 什么我有钱他自己选的和我有什么关系
Nicous: What do you mean I have money? He chose it himself, what's it got to do with me?
Katrina: 这是哪个色号的遮瑕
Katrina: Which shade of concealer is this?